[Music]
ahoy mateys
the countdown to rares March 20th
release of their swashbuckling pirate
game sea of thieves is officially
underway
and throughout the past few weeks we
dove into some of the titles latest
improvements during a studio visit and
various betas from pirate legends to
skeleton raids to the Kraken and beyond
here are 10 things we learned about
Microsoft's first exclusive title of
2018
[Music]
number one sailing the beautiful high
seas based on our experience with the
game thus far it's clear that rares
pirate adventure game is absolutely
gorgeous as the Sun sets and Rises on
the sea of Thieves rares use of Unreal
Engine 4 shines brightly aside from the
game's graphical quality its cartoon art
style complements the comedic and silly
aspects of the game like firing fellow
crewmates out of cannons or playing
pirate dress-up with Goofy accessories
sea of thieves art style is both
beautifully designed and humorously
quirky all at the same time number 2
thrilling pirate voyages voyages our sea
of thieves version of quests and you'll
need to visit an outpost to purchase a
voyage from one of the games three trade
companies the first faction is the gold
hoarders these gilded NPCs challenge you
to hunt for treasure via x marks the
spot maps and solving riddles the second
company is the order of souls these
mysterious NPCs will pay pirates to go
on bounty hunt for the most deadly
pirate captains the third and final
trade company that we know of is the
merchants alliance they will pay you to
scout for supplies like pigs chickens or
gunpowder across the sea the only caveat
is you must fulfill your contract on
time number three team up or go alone
it's no secret that sea of thieves is a
unique type of multiplayer game that
operates best when players adventure in
groups and communicate properly with one
another the larger galleon sailed by a
crew of four are not only better
equipped they are also more sturdy when
it comes to attacks yet if you prefer to
explore the world alone a single sailed
sloop is the perfect alternative these
small vessels are more nimble than
galleons but are far more fragile
everything necessary to operate the ship
including the sails wheel anchor and
math are within arm's reach even for
solo pirates number four guns at the
ready it's important to survey the seas
as danger lurks around every corner ship
the ship combat on the open ocean can be
chaos as the cannonballs whiz by you'll
need to juggle firing back
repairing holes and steering your vessel
while scouring the various islands on
foot you'll often run into other crews
your skeleton or its protecting their
treasures sword fights and gunplay can
be a little clunky but it's a pirate's
life for all and you'll need to fight
for your precious cargo number 5 dress
the part when you first fire up sea of
thieves you'll be greeted by the
infinite pirate generator you'll be able
to circle through eight pre-created
pirates coming in different shapes sizes
genders and appearances if none fit your
preference you can regenerate the eight
characters over and over again until you
find one you'd like to roleplay then at
outpost shops you can spend your
hard-earned gold on a ton of cosmetic
items to dress up your Buccaneer from
full costumes to peg legs how you choose
to outfit your character will allow you
to further standout rare has confirmed
that microtransactions will be in the
final game but stated there will not be
a loop box system nor will purchases
affect gameplay number 6 game-changing
treasures during the various Vedas
players discover two uniquely designed
chests with some interesting effects the
chest of a thousand rods will make the
carrier drunk immediately and the chest
of sorrow will periodically cry and fill
your ship with water if you don't bail
quickly these cursed chests are meant to
change the way you play the game and
although these chests might seem like an
unnecessary challenge they are worth
your trouble as they can be sold for far
more gold than
most regular chests rare has teased more
of these odd chests but we don't know
what effects they will have on the
player or the world around them
number seven skeleton forts since the
first sea of Thieves trailers launched
players have speculated about the scope
cloud with glowing green eyes we now
know it's one of the titles emergent
gameplay systems a giant skull cloud
will randomly appear above a particular
skeleton fort which informs all pirate
crews that a raid is going down as crews
converge on the island they can choose
to work together or battle each other
through the waves of enemies skeletons
once you've fought your way through the
Horde the captain will appear and
challenge you to a battle when the
captain is defeated the cloud will
dissipate and the skeleton will drop a
key to the fort's vault
once the vault is open other crews are
free to pillage
but how raids will transpire is up to
the players can crews work together or
will there be an all-out war for the
vault contents
[Music]
number eight become a pirate legend as
you level up your reputation with the
various factions you'll eventually be
approached by a mysterious group of NPCs
who you'll want to impress this is the
first form of endgame content once
you've proven your worth you'll be
invited into the tavern of Legends which
is hidden somewhere on the existing map
inside the secluded tavern the ghostly
pirate Lord will sell you legendary
voyages and although these voyages are
by far the most valuable in the game
they can still be shared with other
pirates regardless of their rank when
the first pirate legends arrive in the
hideout you'll begin to see some unique
cosmetic items and high ranking titles
sailing throughout the world
number 9 become a legendary captain for
the game's first major update rare has
planned yet another achievement to
strive towards becoming a legendary
captain the second tier of endgame
content makes the tavern of Legends your
personal hideout as you'll automatically
spawn there when signing on this ship
waiting in the background of the cave
will also become yours to sail and
customize when other players see the
legendary ships sail out for underneath
the hideouts waterfall imagine the
Batmobile bursting out of the back aged
they'll know a legendary captain is on
the Seas number 10 released the Kraken
finally we can confirm that the Kraken
patrols the oceans deep acting as a
force of nature similar to the game
storms that can emerge at any time
alongside details shared by rare we also
got our first glimpse at the monster
when screenshots leaked online this past
February the ocean will grow dark with
ink and the in-game music will begin to
change if the Beast draws near if you
are unable to outrun it the Kraken will
wrap its giant tentacles around your
ship and any other ships nearby
attempting to crush them beneath its
weight crew members can be attacked
thrown and thrashed around if you don't
bring the fight to its suction-cup
dilemma
there will be a reward if you and your
crew are able to take down the Kraken
but we will have to wait to find out
what that might be from the features
highlighted on this list - the
additional updates rare continues to
roll out see if thieves progression is
just getting started I for one am
excited to see what kind of Easter eggs
rare has in store for us as we scour the
Seas for remnants of banjo kazooie or
perfect dark so be sure to keep an eye
on gamespot.com for the latest sea of
thieves updates and our review later
this month
[Music]
[Music]